every graduation
people get really excited about
being an adult
and then they die and so this dude he's
a baseball player in Baton Rouge and
there's a video of him it's sad this is
sad we're watching someone get eaten by
a shark or we think we are we don't
really know
so Cameron who I'm sure was a lovely guy
maybe who knows I don't know I'm sure he
was
but what he's done now for these people
that were on that boat
they have one of the most amazing
Stories I would work it into everything
I don't care where I was or what I was
doing I would absolutely I would always
bring it up and it's quick that's the
beauty of it it's in and out what a
great [__] way to start the summer